Hey everyone Diavolo here and today we’re
finally back after a few months break from
Chainsaw Man, to get straight back into the
next Dating Denji Arc from the Academy Saga
or Part 2.
For those curios as to where I was with CSM,
cause I saw ya comments, I had to wait for
those chapters to build up and allow to me
to fully binge the series, catching back up
on the Fujimoto goodness i've missed out on
for a little bit now.
After complete my Chainsaw Man fasting, I
can say it was more than worth it.
I always enjoy just sitting back and having
my mind blown with just how creative this
man actually is and this arc is no different.
Its might be slower in parts, but we get to
see an old Devil friend, Asa and Denji’s
characters finally connect on a different
level and damn the foreshadowing as to what
could come next up is mental.
So if you want more chainsaw man content,
help push this video to 5k likes so I know
your all keen on the next arc, but either
way sit back and relax as we watch Asa Mitaka
make a complete fool of herself!
So, Denji still stuck with Asa at the Aquarium
building (remember thats where we left chainsaw
man at the end of the last arc, Asa from memory
bumped into Fami who showed up during our
duo’s date).
Either way, Denji explains to her that the
Eternity Devil has taken over the building
but she refuses to believe him.
Having walked over 100 meters in a straight
line, Asa wonder how long the hallway is.
Denji tries to convince her that it is the
Eternity Devils thing.
Still, she screams at him to shut up as she
cant believe the fact that Denji is even a
devil hunter, instead asking him to stop making
things up while confidently claiming that
she knows more as she’s actually in the
Devil Hunter club.
From a distance The Devil Hunter Club members
all pull up along side and even back up Asa
by revealing that she actually knows a lot
about Devils.
While Denji who btw has no idea who the Devil
Hunter club members are, Hiruka, the president
of the group, introduces himself but immediately
gets cut off in a savage manner by Denji who
notices that Yoshida actually showed up aswell.
Standing there, Yoshida tells Denji that he
ended up in this whole mess just because he
wanted to check out some fishes at the aquarium
but got trapped there instead by a nasty devil.
Seigi informs Yoshida that the guy who turned
up turns out to be the guy who went from Civilian
Devil Hunter to Public Safety Devil Hunter
while still in High School.
Again the Student Council President introduces
himself BUT just like last time he’s cut
off as Kobeni’s brother Higashimiya, shows
up and reveals that this isn’t a dream,
they’re being attacked by a real-life devil.
On top of that, he reveals that he never really
wanted to join the Devil Hunter Club and that
he only did so because his mother said it’d
get him a scholarship.
NOW THIS IS A TRUE MAMA’S BOY and I FREEEAKING
LOVE the fact that this is so similar to the
first time we meet the Eternity Devil with
Kobeni freaking out, but also so different
as pretty much every facet of the story has
changed!
Anyways, Its explained that a devil’s power
makes the hallway go on forever and the only
way out is if they kill the devil or themselves.
Wanting to know if they saw any Devils beforehand
Denji asks, only to be told no.
Asa remembering what Famine had previously
told her, wonders if she should turn Denji
into a weapon or kill Haruka, who she believes
is the real Chainsaw Man.
Asa believes that if she can actually kill
him, then she could get her body back from
Yoru without turning anyone around into a
weapon.
Moving forth through the building, the members
of the Devil Hunter Club are able to obtain
fish and water from an endlessly repeating
staff room that they found.
Together, they eventually figure out a way
to cook by starting a fire with someone's
lighter and the scrap newspapers lying around.
A few moments later, Asa reveals that she
can’t eat fish since it looks too much like
a dead animal and totally it grosses her out.
She hurrilidly leaves the room and sighs in
front of the door, before bumping into Denji
who gives her a suspicious look.
It turns out Denji was just picking up a 1000
yen bag from the ground, but Asa accuses him
of being a thief.
Filled with ill contempt for our vomit eating
creep, Asa gives Denji a moral lesson knowing
almost nothing about the things Denji would
actually do for money all while continuing
to argue with him.
After a few tense moments between the two
where they both tell each other to go to hell
(which ima just say is probably a massive
foreshadowing in it self), Asa believes that
she should really turn Denji into a weapon.
After he leaves, she stands there alone for
a moment and confirms to herself that she
isn't a loser like Denji and will contribute
to the Devil Hunters Club somehow.
Back in the room now, Asa takes out her mom’s
phone looking for a signal, which of course,
got all of the group members excited.
When Asa manages to find a signal bar for
one second, she immediately stretches her
arm in an attempt to find it again, but as
everyone coomes with just how lucky they are,
and that they’re all gonna be saved, Asa
just ends up tripping over her own feet and
falls to the ground.
Guess what?
like it would have been fine if it wasn't
some bung ass flip phone, but due to her mom
skimping out on the modern device her phone
snapped in half as it fell to the ground.
AND OML this brings back some memories, in
school when I was like 13 I used to have this
sick super dope army grade flip phone.
I could throw this thing like 50 meters in
to the air and it'd survive ANYTHING, until...
one day it flipped open in midair and helicoptered
its way to death, snapping like Asa’s phone.
Looking at just how pathetic Asa is, Haruka
sighs and comments that he expected better
from her.
Instead Asa complains all the time, failing
to come through in clutch always letting them
down.
Hearing this, Asa panics and immediately leaves
the room to cry in isolation outside the room.
Lying down now, Asa ponders whether the Aquarium
is from hell since once you get in, there’s
no way out.
The hallway goes on endlessly, and clock hands
don’t even move!
You can’t even flush the toilets here, and
to top things off, the fishes start rotting
in their tanks.
Having moved into the hallway himself, Haruka
throws some abuse at Asa for breaking the
cell phone or else they would have escaped.
Asa believes that Haruka is Chainsaw Man and
asks why he doesn't do something, which actually
confuses Haruka who wonders what the hell
she’s even talking about.
Pointing out the starter on his chest, Haruka
clarifies that the starter is a surgical implant,
and it’s one of the reasons why people say
that the man who comes the closest to Chainsaw
Man.
That’s why he’s President of the Chainsaw
Man Society’s High School chapter, Runner-up
in the Chainsaw Man Quiz Show Contest, and
owner of every piece of Chainsaw Man Merchandise!
Bro is a simp for Chainsaw Man.
Be like bro.
Just to make sure she’s correct, Asa asks
Haruka about being Chainsaw Man one last time,
to which he starts hysterically laughing while
telling here that if he was Chainsaw Man,
they could have broken out of the hellhole
in no time.
Seconds after he begins screaming for chainsaw
man to come and save him, sending a fat SOS
to Denji who’s right around the corner yarning
with Yoshida.
As the two stand there in silence, Yoshida
speaks up about how it’s our boy Denji’s
cue to help Asa.
Denji on the other hand reveals that he was
able to kill the devil last time because the
devil himself came at them but this devil
is nowhere to be found so how can he defeat
it?
All of a sudden, Yoshida reveals a cellphone
that he also had hidden, but points out he
hasn't been able to find a signal and it feels
like it’s been over three days that they've
been trapped in the aquarium.
In his eyes everyone seems to have given up,
and Yoshida himself has also made peace with
death.
Turning to Denji, he asks if Chainsaw Man
would eat the DEATH devil for them, leaving
our man with a spaced out look, clueless as
to what Yoshida was referring too.
As time moves forth, Denji goes to Asa who’s
sitting inside one of the smaller fish tanks.
He notes that the others are all starting
to lose, but wonders how she’s holding out.
Hearing that she’s hungry, Denji just tells
her to eat some fish but she refuses claiming
she cant eat it.
She also apologizes to Denji for asking him
on a date, explaining that it’s her fault
for how he ended up in this situation, and
how Denji probably has no idea that she’s
trying to turn him into a weapon.
However now, even starving and pushed into
a corner, she just cant do it.
She reveals that she doesn’t have the guts
to do anything and has no idea what’s right
or wrong.
Her entire below average life has just been
one long string of attempts to avoid any mistakes
and thats why she’s just a total bore.
Denji not overly concerned with what she was
muttering, sits right in front of her and
notes that yeah she cant eat fish right?
Then flipping out a star fish as if its like
the left leg of exodia, he asks Asa if she’s
ever tried this?
Being our big brain neuro divergent genius,
Asa immediately protested as a starfish is
toxic and has to be boiled first.
Of course though, our boy right here is just
as resourceful as ever, so they look for a
random pot lid and a pot to boil the starfishes.
While they’re cooking, Asa notices tons
of school hats lying right by her side.
Denji reveals that he collected these hats
to sell them after he gets out of the Aquarium,
causing our girl to question Denji’s obsession
with money.
Denji clarifies that he just wants to support
his “sorta-friend sorta-little sister thats
living with him”.
Denji being the muppet he is believes that
Nayuta is smart enough to go to college and
because of that is saving for her tuition.
He reveals to Asa that before he got to where
he is now his life was super crappy and he
wants her to have a normal one.
Soon, the starfishes get ready and the duo
start smashing them back.
Asa says that feeding on starfishes isn’t
enough, but looking over to her right she
notices dried fish and after asking Denji,
tries to eat them.
She hesitates at first but eventually manages
to chow down with tears in her eyes.
Thinking that this was fun, Denji says that
everything Asa says is boring but she's interesting
to watch.
Oooh if these ain’t early symptoms of simping,
then I don’t know what it is, anyways.
On the other hand, Asa is confused by this
statement until the power of self-confidence
hits her causing her to stand up and say that
Denji has a good eye for people, and with
this new level of confidence flowing through
her she says that she’s charming isn't she.
Our simp boy Denji tells how he loves Asa’s
attitude and reveals how it reminds him of
an old friend who’s most likely to be Power
(may her soul rest in peace).
After munching on dried fish, Asa asks for
Denji’s help to find a way out of the Aquarium.
Asa explains the plan which is nothing more
than to collect money.
Rushing down the hall, Denji further discusses
their plan and how there is a thousand yen
in the backpack on the ground, and there is
also a wallet with fourteen thousand yen inside
it back at the lounge.
Asa who was previously giving Denji a moral
lesson in theft, now also wants to steal money
in order to escape the Aquarium.
LOOK WHO DECIDED TO SWITCH SIDES.
Pushing forth, its shown that as the two rob
the Eternity Devil over and over again their
having the best time of their lives, joking
around and laughing.
After they’re done collecting the money,
Asa asks for the entire bag of money.
Denji hesitates at first since he’s giving
away such a huge amount of money, like its
literally over a million yen now.
BUT she manages to persuades him by saying
that she’ll grant him any request once they
do escape.
Immediately Denji gives away all of the collected
money to Asa.
While collecting it she asks Denji to just
listen to her for now, so go over and stand
in a corner with his eyes closed and ears
covered!
Doing exactly what he’s told, Denji walks
over and stands up against the wall.
Telling herself to have some confidence, Asa
reminds herself that regardless of how absurd
the reasoning may seem, it ultimately comes
down to her own perspective.
She urges herself to have faith in her abilities
and decides to set aside the million yen bag
to purchase the Aquarium.
With her eyes still closed and the bag along
with Denji seemingly vanished she places her
hands against the glass and commands the Aquarium
Spear.
Money is a sensitive topic to talk about,
but while Denji is still skeptical about his
decision of handing over the money to Asa,
he still believes that after obeying Asa,
he will get what he wishes for, so it’s
all good.
Randomly, Denji sees a penguin coming his
way, so he starts playing with it.
Suddenly, Denji holding this cute lil penguin,
along with all of the students appear outside
the Aquarium.
Obviously this was thanks to Asa who managed
to weasel her way out of the original conditions.
If you forgot the original conditions were
that Asa had to kill the Chainsaw Man to leave
the Aquarium.
The Eternity Devil also shows up right in
front of her screams that this wasn't the
deal, you can’t buy an aquarium with a measly
million yen.
Seeing the devil towering over Asa, Yoshida
quickly intervenes and saves our girl.
Having closed her eyes previously, Asa transforms
into Yoru who having read Asa’s memories,
notes that of-course she’d feel guilty for
destroying an aquarium.
Darting at her, the Eternity Devil's screams
for her to die, however Yoru easily manages
to defend herself with the Aquarium spear
and while getting ready to throw it asks if
the Devil was sure 1 million wasn't enough?
she was determined to prove her worth and
claim what she desired, no matter the cost.
At last, Yoru sends the spear flying forth,
which in a matter of moments connects and
sends a plethora of sharks and other marine
life flying everywhere.
In turn this attack also defeats the Eternity
Devil and leaves everyone nearby baffled with
the change in Asa.
Atop a nearby building Famine remarks that
well that idea went to hell, then looking
down her eyes gaze catches Yoshida and the
two begin staring at each other.
After the battle, Asa thanks Denji for walking
her home while calling it the worst date ever.
However, surprisingly, Denji enjoyed it as
he got to touch a penguin as well.
Awkwardly Denji brings up the request part
again and asks if Asa would still grant him
any request; Intrigued Asa asks what kind
of request it was.
Denji was filled with excitement as he proposed
going on another date with Asa.
YOU MIGHT’VE THOUGHT DENJI WAS GOING TO
ASK FOR SOMETHING LEWD, BUT NO!
He has his head set straight for the first
time in his life!
With his extensive dating experience, he eagerly
volunteered to be her guide, promising to
show her the ropes of creating the most memorable
and extraordinary outings.
Well, his dating experience just sums up with
him being with the most dangerous woman in
the verse.
BUT Asa's face instantly lit up with a gentle
smile, her heart beating rapidly with anticipation.
It was at that moment that Yoru realized she
might be on the verge of falling in love.
However, even as Asa's emotions swirled within
her, she remained cautious.
Talk about trust issues, huh?
Putting her guard up, Yoru confessed to Asa
that she had never expected to develop feelings
for someone as unconventional and rough around
the edges as him.
Its only plausible because she shares in Asa’s
feelings aswell, still in her crazed eye’s
she believes they they can still continue
with the original plan.
Confused Asa lowers her head before randomly
walking forth and affectionately patting Denji's
head.
With her hand on his head its revealed that
Asa and Yoru had switched places and in that
moment she chants the words "Denji Spinal
Cord Sword."
BUT IT DOESN’T SEEM TO WORK!
Denji's confusion persisted as Yoru continuously
patted his head while saying “Denji Spinal
Cord Sword,” expecting it to trigger a transformation.
Almost every lady Denji encountered has tried
to destroy him, and turn him into a tool.
Funnily enough Yoru’s efforts proved to
be fruitless, leaving Denji perplexed and
unsure of what was even happening.
Attempting to make sense of the situation,
Denji gently patted Asa on the head, then
with a sense of uncertainty, copied the words
"Asa Spinal Cord Sword" before walking off
and joking that this was a fun way to say
goodbye!
In a separate conversation, Asa and Yoru exchanged
thoughts on Denji's inability to transform
despite their efforts.
Well, what can we say?
Denji is quite literally built different,
on a serious note though it probably has something
to do with her feeling some kinda way bout
our man.
Frustration filled their voices as they mentioned
how annoying the situation is.
Thinking on it, Asa questions if it means
Denji doesn't like her that way, not that
it really matters since she totally doesn't
either!
Nevertheless Yoru points out that they both
share emotions, which is a new thing for her.
Still they will take their time to actually
win Denji’s heart while searching for Chainsaw
Man on a larger scale.
Yoru states that its probably best they get
some sleep, however Asa brings up the girl
who trapped everyone in the Aquarium and if
she was related to Yoru.
Yoru clarifies that she was the Famine Devil
and she actually hadn't seen her in a while,
hence why she didnt recognize her initially.
Exhausted from their efforts, Yoru collapses
onto the bed, wanting to rest however, Asa,
ever mindful of personal hygiene, offered
a well-intentioned suggestion.
She gently advised Yoru to take a bath before
settling down to sleep.
Asa and Yoru then went to bed, her mind consumed
by thoughts of Denji and the conflicting emotions
his words had stirred within her.
She pondered over his heartfelt expressions,
spoken seemingly in contradiction to his lack
of fondness for her.
Asa's frustration grew, fueled by the belief
that if Denji truly disliked her, he shouldn't
have said such a sincere and compassionate
statement.
She wrestled with the complexity of their
relationship finally ending on the take that
she’s quite unsatisfied with how irritating
he is and actually hates him.
After a while and probably the next day after
class, Asa goes out and reunites with the
squad where Denji shares the ideas of his
“super best date ever.”
Denji suggests that he and Asa should watch
Mummy movies nonstop till 2 AM for only 2000
yen.
2000 yen though, thats like 20 bucks and in
Asa’s eyes renting movies out would be much
easier and more convenient, she also shares
the fact that she doesn’t like pricey dates.
Slightly bummed out that she didnt go with
his plan, Denji agrees to her plan and panics
when Asa suggests going over to his place
since its even cheaper that way.
Blown away with the change out events Denji
awkwardly tells Asa that there will be a few
rules that she has to follow if she does come
over.
With her questioning this, he reveals that
you cant break these rules no matter what,
because if you do in the worst case scenario,
it could result in her death.
Sneaking up behind the duo, Haruka eavesdrops
on their conversation and gets alerted when
he hears Denji mention that someone can die.
The much-awaited day had finally arrived when
a girl was scheduled to visit Denji's humble
abode.
As anticipation filled the air, Denji took
a moment to caution Asa about a rule named
"Unbreakable Rule 1."
He emphasized the importance of refraining
from opening any other apartment door, ensuring
that their privacy and the sanctity of their
neighbors' spaces were respected.
As Asa stepped inside, our simp boy Denji
guided her towards the cozy seating area right
in front of the television.
Just as the excitement settled in, Denji revealed
the existence of a second rule which is to
refrain from opening the refrigerator.
But Asa already knew all too well the common
sense of never invading the sacred territory
of another person's fridge.
With the atmosphere brimming with curiosity
and amusement, Denji proceeded to disclose
the most vital rule which was rule number
3.
He shared the delightful news that his roommate,
a lover of furry friends, had ventured out
to walk their beloved dogs; he also added
how his roommate is somewhat of a problem
child, so no matter what happens, Asa is prohibited
to make out with him in front of her.
Asa gets annoyed and flustered after hearing
Denji talk like she’ll actually make out
with him.
Asa starts sarcastically asking Denji whether
he thinks she likes him, to which Denji responds
that he’s been thinking about how she asked
him on a date, so figured that she must 90
percent like him.
Without any further discussion, Asa goes defensive
mode and clarifies that there is no way she
likes him, infact its actually the contrary,
she hates Denji more than anything.
Asa reveals that just like Denji she also
has rules and needs to stay away from her
or he’ll just end up dead.
In an attempt to divert her attention, Asa
confesses that she initially agreed to the
date with Denji as a means of distracting
herself, fully intending to leave right after
watching the movie together.
As time passes, the weight of this revelation
finally dawns on Denji, causing him to question
whether Asa has been using him all along.
Doubt begins to creep into his mind, wondering
if he's somehow at fault for the current predicament.
As these thoughts swirl in Denji's head, he
can't help but recall a distant memory.
Someone had once remarked that he smelled
like a dog, but rather than taking offense,
he had mistaken it for a compliment…
Now, in deep thought he wonders if there was
more to that comment than he initially thought.
Has his unique scent played a role in the
way others perceive him?
The question lingers in his mind, adding another
layer of self-doubt to his already tangled
emotions.
As Denji thought about his complicated situation,
he came to a simple conclusion: Asa must dislike
him because of the way he smells.
Despite this, Denji couldn't deny the fact
he did slightly like her, but if this is how
it is then thats that.
With a resolution to improve himself, he decided
to stop sleeping with the dogs, however just
as he contemplated the absurdity of these
changes, a surprising twist occurred.
Asa, transformed into Yoru, leaned forth and
passionately kissed him out of the blue.
Denji's mind reeled with astonishment, trying
to make sense of the sudden turn of events.
THIS WAS HIS ONE AND ONLY DREAM!
Yet, before he could fully comprehend the
situation, the door suddenly opened and a
pack of dogs entered the apartment.
Turning around and screaming as the dogs begin
jumping on them, the notice a short shadowy
figure in the doorway.
Just when the situation couldn’t get worse,
Nayuta happened!
She came back to the apartment and witnessed
Denji’s lewd make-out session.
Pointing forth while calling Asa a thief,
a random chain appears from the tip of her
finger that shoots forth and implants itself
directly into the brain of the War Devil.
To Denji’s astonishment, Yoru immediately
hops on all fours and fearlessly unleashed
her own inner dog, barking back at the rowdy
canines.
What caught our boy more off-guard though
was that Yoru's barks proved to be a secret
weapon, silencing the dogs and leaving them
utterly dumbfounded.
Nayuta witnessing it all burst into an evil
kind of laughter.
Annoyed Denji who somehow didnt figure it
out, demands to know what Nayuta done, to
which the child proclaims that she turned
her into a DOG!
You know the parallels here is pretty funny,
just comparing it to Denji’s experience
with Makima, and when he turned into a dog.
Its random watching Asa seemingly speed-run
everything that Denji’s been through previously.
Denji demands the reasoning as to why she’d
even do that, and Nayuta just casually states
that its because she put spit on her property.
Baffled, Denji screams that he’s literally
his own property and demands that she turn
his friend back this instant.
Nayuta denies it to start with, but after
Denji offers to cook her something she agree’s
to turn her back later.
As time skipped forth its shown that like
every other puppy, Yoru had fallen asleep
between the dogs while cuddling them; on the
other hand, Denji and Nayuta have a meal amidst
their own chaos.
Denji asks Nayuta to turn his friend back
into her original self, but knowing that every
girl Denji’s ever meet has tried to kill
him, questions what makes her different.
After hearing Denji’s laxed reply, Nayuta
states that she will return her to normal,
however only if Denji abides by two conditions.
First, she demands to be able to eat ice cream
every day, while the other requires Denji
to never get friendly with Asa.
Nayuta reasoning for this is that she simply
doesn't like Asa’s scent.
Denji asks if she smells like a wet dog (obviously
mans trying to confirm his previous doubts),
Nayuta screams back though that wet dogs actually
smell nice.
To fix everything that happened back at their
apartment, Nayuta explains that she’ll alter
Asa’s memories so she thinks Denji just
stood her up.
Denji got a little worried to start with since
Asa might end up hating him, but Nayuta re-iterates
that he’s done with her either way so its
not like it even matters.
After completing the memory alteration, we
see Asa standing right in front of the high
school thinking that Denji stood her up.
Confused with it all, Yoru just pushes her
feelings aside and things its best they start
targeting a different boy.
On the way home now, she doubts herself, thinking
that he must've forgotten, not that she’d
ever care.
This was all to warn Denji to stay away from
her.
She didn't mean to spend that much money on
dating plus she also had to do her schoolwork,
so Asa is glad that she got stood up.
Nevertheless, she confesses to herself and
acknowledges this feeling of longing to experience
even the tiniest desire for human contact,
but also realizes that such emotions arose
solely due to being with someone of the opposite
gender for an extended duration.
So basically, those were her hormones talking!!
At the end of the day, Asa’s priority is
to beat Chainsaw Man and get her body back,
which means there’s no reason for Asa to
be stuck on Denji; especially since she actually
prefers solitude more than anything else.
In that way, Asa might have an easier time
attaining her own personal happiness without
relying on Denji.
After a while and having returned to the school,
she starts to wonder what the is even wrong
with her, all she should care about is getting
her body back.
DAMN FUJIMOTO idk why but his writings just
resonate with me, that all enveloping fear
of loneliness strikes some cord within me.
EITHER WAY breaking that awkwardness, Yoshida
randomly shows up asking what’s wrong with
Asa and why is she standing there.
Then continuing with Yoshida’s random randomness,
he steps forth and asks if she’d like to
keep him company for a bit?
So that there brings us to the end of this
Dating Denji Arc, re-reading this section
of CSM full on made me realize just how similar
both Asa and Denji are, like the personalities
are polar opposites but the experiences seem
to be suuuper similar and im enjoying it so
far.
Next time and hopefully soon ill be back with
the FALLING DEVIL ARC, so if you are interested
and want me to keep more upto date with Chainsaw
Man then leave a like and try help in pushing
this video to 5k likes.
Also if you are new around here and want content
just like this but for a multitude of different
series, then make sure to subscribe.
BUT either way for now its been ya professional
degenerate Diavolo and ill see you all in
a bit, bye! <3